>>Human beings are born storytellers.
We're communicators.
That's in our DNA, the need to
reach out and to communicate.
And we do it through voice, we do it
through gesture, all those things.
But if you think about it, human
communication is gone in an instant.
My voice is gone in an instant,
this gesture's gone in an instant.
So, we've been creating technology
to extend communication
across time and space.
Writing, at the base, is technology.
It's something we have created to
extend communication into the future.
So, new digital tools, internet
technology, it's the next leap,
maybe a quantum leap, maybe an
evolutionary leap, in the technology
that we've created to
communicate and to work together.
>>So, thinking about this evolution,
I always think about three things
that even in my lifetime
have dramatically changed.
One thing is I can remember
when I was a kid it used to be
that the writer made the words, the
writer handed them to a new person,
that new person was an editor.
That editor was followed
by a publisher, a designer,
someone who distributed and
marketed and circulated the book.
Well, all of these professional
niches now can be done
by one person using
new digital tools.
We can create content,
we can design it,
we can circulate it,
we can promote it.
We can do the whole package.
>>Two, we can control
our own publication.
Anybody can circulate
content to any other person
if they're connected via the
internet, point to point,
one computer to one
computer, anywhere.
So, we don't have to go through
controlled channels anymore.
We can share with and learn
from anybody else connected
to the internet.
>>And the third thing I think
of is the opportunity actually
to link those computers together
to collaborate among people,
to create ever more sophisticated
maps of content, pieces of content,
to build knowledge together,
even if actually we've never
met and may never meet.
All of these things have
very low barriers of entry.
So, actually, these things,
which just a few years ago could
only be done by professionals
after long periods of apprenticeship
with really expensive equipment,
now can be done by anybody.
They can be done by children.
They can be done by adults.
They can be done in
school or out of school.
So, the capacity to be able to do
ever-more sophisticated writing
at ever-younger ages,
it's just there.
It's just in front of us.
>>Well, just because, of course,
the tools that we use to write
and publish might be
getting ever-easier
to use doesn't mean writing
itself is any easier.
To write well really means to really
think about purpose and audience,
to be able to really have
credibility, to study, to prepare,
to be able to put something out there
that really represents something
significant that you want to say.
And that's no easier just
because the tools we use
to make it might be
getting easier to use.
>>So, now that we can all actually
see our writing be published we
probably have to engage with the
fact that we really are writers.
When we put something on YouTube
we really are a video maker.
When we build a website we
really are a content publisher.
And so that means we actually have
to be much more attentive to craft.
We really have to take
more responsibility
for what we put out there.
>>That's a change I think.
And with that craft comes
actually the knowledge
of some new kinds of writing.
We certainly still have novels, and
we certainly still have the long form
in journalism, and people who
make their living as authors,
but when I edit a Wikipedia entry
I'm actually thinking a little
differently about my writing.
I'm thinking both about what I want
to say, but how what I'm writing fits
in this amazingly larger context.
So, the sense that I'm a
participant and a contributor,
as opposed to a kind of lone,
solitary author, is really different.
And it really means a more
collaborative stance on writers
and more of a sense of
building knowledge together.
>>The issue in in this really
rapidly changing innovative moment
in communications technology.
How do we help students?
How do we help young people
understand the form, the context,
the purpose, the potential in
the tools, and get ready to learn
about that, about ever-new tools?
It's not what's out there today.
For teachers it's not whether you're
using Facebook or Twitter so much
as it's how are we preparing people
to be able to use what's going
to be there in five
and ten years from now.
>>The real core of learning to write
and teaching writing isn't
actually about the tool.
It's actually about what you're
going to do with the tool.
It's about becoming better with
audience, better with purpose,
better with what I really want
to say, clearer about that,
more collaborative and able
to make draft by draft,
iteration by iteration,
something that's better.
Students can come into school
knowing how to use a pencil,
doesn't mean that that
exhausts everything there is
in learning to write.
They can come in learning how
to use, and knowing how to use,
a lot of these social
environments and tools and programs.
We should use that and bring
that into the classroom,
because there's still going to be
something for the teacher to work
on with the students about getting
better, about getting broader.
>>So, we need to be thinking and
teaching, not for today, but for 10,
20, 50 years from now
when actually we settle
into a world that's now been
transformed by the internet
and transformed by digital tools.
So, the moment to capture is not now,
the moment to capture is the future.